you think you know me
you don't growing up i was surrounded by
rage
this rage fueled me into a champion
but outside the ring the rage fueled my
pain
and darkness surrounded me
out of darkness came light the light was
my path to the future
you think you know me you will
typhoon rant future roller future
rolling
why did you fight without any socks i
didn't thought that was a style i didn't
know these poor [ __ ] didn't
have socks
but isn't it isn't it tough on your feet
man oh man my feet look like they blew
up
all righty it has begun welcome to this
episode of hot boxing with mike tyson i
am your co-host triple c
aka henry cejudo and i'm mike tyson and
who we have here
is matt can i tell you something we have
the cheek
and we have the chong and these are
these men are legendary these are the
first guys
these are the prototypes and they laid
the footwork down for what we're doing
right now
no extra charge congratulations guys
thank you guys come on let's get a round
of applause over here come on
what's up that's what i want in here
oh i love you please sit down sit down
listen listen man
first thing i'm gonna say my balls it
stop my stress my boss
please stretch my balls well okay
but you're right mike speaking about
that i mean you guys have helped pave
the way even for you know for the brown
like tyson's ranch you know you guys
have been in the industry for a minute
getting a chance to look up your story
too tommy i mean you've i mean you went
to federal prison for
you know for for madison that's right
yeah i sure did i enjoyed every minute
of it like uh
yeah yeah it was great we left we
enjoyed it
in the garden that's strong and [ __ ]
yeah i was in fed
we we we didn't know we weren't allowed
but they all had it yeah yeah exactly
no but check this out mike and he
haven't said he went to federal prison
for selling bongs
no not selling them shipping them oh
shipping
shipping them across the state line it's
like white slavery but with bongs
yeah and you know who wrote that law
it's across straight lines for
moral purposes you know you you know who
wrote that law
joe biden jabbing joe
ogio yeah i think but joe's trying to
hey listen i have to for his defense
joe's trying to come back for the for
the cannabis he's trying to he's going
to be punished
he know he was wrong he was wrong he's
trying to write himself i think so
i think i like what he's doing no i got
i i supported biden you know i
got to go with the man with the good
heart like i said
i enjoyed jail
it was it was all right what does this
[ __ ] was trying to get my high school my
diploma mother
they said just write down anything and
we'll pass you
i said what the [ __ ] is it i was trying
to
they told me you could keep your your
computer you know
and you could just do it and i believed
them yeah and so when they had the test
they took all the computers away from
you
we had our own private uh gang
a car we called it and four of us we
uh we ran the garden you know the the
the we grew fresh vegetables for the
uh food bank not for the prison for the
food bank
so we had this incredible garden hot
peppers and everything
and then we had we'd order chicken from
the commissary
you buy it we cooked our own meals
and we've done a lot of prisons over the
years san quentin folsom
solar dad and everybody in there capable
of killing
every [ __ ] god ladies
holy [ __ ] he pulled the gun out and
fired it off in prison in san quentin
oh yeah i swear to god we're doing a
comedy routine for all the prisoners
that was weird man because people would
come up and talk to you and you go
look around where the [ __ ] are they they
they'd whisper you know because you're
not supposed to make eye contact
and so they it was weird and some were
and they're all in front
and the guys in the what do you call it
the
protection the guards the ones that got
beat up they're
being protected yeah yeah they're
they're behind a fence and they're
trying to see around the
corner the the uh see us on stage
but we did this bit and he was reverend
dyke remember reverend
i remember i from new york exactly and
so he was he got all my mothers
reverend dyke and he was going to save
somebody and and
a girl saved a woman we had these girls
that were were stripper dancers that
were friends of
of
no this is for real we're in san quentin
we're entertaining the troops there
and and and so we had this bit where
he's reverend dyke
and he's going to save a girl so he
chooses this girl one of the servers who
danced before us
in in in the prison with the champion
volunteered to do it
if you can follow naked women and san
quentin man then you've got to act
and so comes the part where he's going
to save it and i come running out
from the from the from the backstage
just like a samurai with a sword
and i come ah like here and he and he
pulls out
it was part of the act a starter pistol
a pistol 45
45 and he goes pow pow pow it has blanks
in it
in san quentin and she falls dead and i
said
i've saved her i have saved that young
lady the [ __ ] guards were out here
it was like part of the yard
one question i want to ask you man why
did you fight without any socks
i know i used to see all these old-time
jacks and all these [ __ ]
i didn't know they um they were i didn't
thought that was a style i didn't know
these poor [ __ ] didn't have
socks they didn't have socks
it was just stuff they're no socks you
bought the guys you pour the buy socks
but isn't it isn't it tough on your feet
man oh man my feet look like um
man man they look like they blew up yeah
i'm gonna flush those feet huh you got
tough feet mike
my tough feet look i'm like the brother
you'll see that movie the brother from
another planet when he had the
pterodactyl feet
he gave that girl he sat with this girl
gave this [ __ ] stitches and [ __ ] she's
all cut about to go to the emergency
room
uh-huh i doesn't impress me more than
anything man those [ __ ] black shoes
with no socks
oh
brother you really had style man you
projected
yeah but you guys i watched you guys for
entertainment back there
yeah i was thinking i was a young kid
too i was in high school
i remember nice dreams one time catch my
bubbles
oh my balls it's a please drop that ball
man can you scratch my balls
i was prepping you for prison man oh yes
you did
oh this is dude i want to smoke some
more oh
how long you been having this show going
on how long
three years two years i was like hey hey
rob
it's been a it's been about a couple of
years i think three years
thank you thank you very much somebody's
here with me three years
three years yes yeah you like it
that time yeah again that time did you
smoke out in prison
i wasn't smoking can you believe this i
started this box and stuff right
and i didn't make the olympic trial so i
was so mad so i stopped smoking at 18
and last time i and then from there 18 i
must have been
how was i in 30 i must have been 33 and
34
and like what 97 what was like 33
97 98 that's when i started smoking when
tupac died to start smoking again
yeah yeah it's good for you that's oh
that's so crazy now i'm a [ __ ]
super duper duper duper pot head
a stoner hey how you got going with the
mushrooms these days
uh i don't want to yeah i heard about
your uh mushroom show with
sugary yeah man those guys ain't cool
with the mushroom man
no no i don't i don't i think i think
it's interesting how
you guys met you guys you guys actually
met in canada yeah yeah yeah he's
canadian
yeah i'm canadian hey hey hey for some
reason
i apologize to me
we have our blood sport though we have
hockey oh absolutely yeah
hockey is a very gentleman gentlemanly
way to
duke it out
yeah yeah cheech was up in uh canada
being a potter
right i was gonna hat to go with the
potter that's it i
was i was the only mexican to sneak into
canada
yeah it was yeah but you guys you guys
met in the in the
the 70s right no 60s aidan end of
6 to 69 8 69
68. i'm well i'm three-year-old
yeah exactly i'm curious to see how you
guys how this whole relationship kind of
developed you know
how does that cultivate this [ __ ] he's
mexican yeah
we know how to cultivate you can't
live in california without your mexicans
yeah so we were starting to try to start
colonies there in canada but
we met in vancouver eventually long
story short remember and tommy was
running
he started at an improvisational theater
group in a topless club
and it was vancouver's first topless
club and he changed it to
be improvisational theater but topless
and so i met him guys too and guys too
and i met him as a writer and i started
writing
you know okay girls take off your
clothes that was the first thing i wrote
and and that went okay and so we started
doing this improv theater
every night four nights seven nights
seven nights a week
seven six years yeah seven every night
four four hours of improv but naked
improv
well you have wood stock no but just
before
yeah no we missed that one i wish we
were we were there yeah
which one woodstock we
i was traveling with my lady from
detroit
got to la met some hippies and he said
come on we're going to new york
i just came from detroit i don't know
i'm staying here
it was woodstock is it been legendary
baby yeah
i go i used to live in catskill new york
so i would go to um
woodstock here's woodstock and um the
hippies from the 60s are still there
yeah they're still there
yeah we've played there again since yeah
they never left they got stuck
that was a watershed man yeah
we played a gig in in bull island
indiana which was basically
just outside of chicago was right after
woodstock and there was
half a million people eight hundred
thousand eight hundred feet that's what
we need eight hundred thousand people
what is that music that we involved with
the ebd
amd emd we that's what um the property
you're watching if that's what that's
for
i don't know there's a thousand acres up
there out in the desert it'll be good
yeah oh man
no that's my hood up there yeah that's
that's what we're building up there
yeah tyson ranch
are you getting raised chickens two
lemons
chicken oh they already got tyson
chicken now we have that tyson meat
stuff oh yeah
yeah what kind vegetarian meat baby the
fake stuff
baby you know you can get what you want
to do about weed
so
mike you're a farmer now hey listen the
greatest warriors ever lived with
farmers
yeah that's who the greatest fighters in
the world are farmers you're outstanding
in your field
i haven't done that i haven't did that
yet i've been humble quite a few times
i bet yeah so what do you what do you
guys think that made
chi chi chong such a dynamic duel the
energy the dynamics of these two guys
and
for us yeah there's a big need there i
am so high
and we filled it
yeah would you would you agree uh cheech
yeah yeah absolutely it was like
we understood each other's backgrounds
he was raised
a half chinese english irish outside of
calgary
with the indian tooth and indian too and
and so naturally he found the only black
people in
in that in alberta and formed the band
with them
and so banana was raised in an all black
neighborhood
and then an all-white neighborhood half
and half and so i understood that whole
that whole culture because we were both
blended yeah that culture so when we
came back to l.a
from canada just make it big that's how
we played as black clubs
and cheech was such a good actor that i
didn't know
he was mexican i mean
don't tell nobody
no we didn't know what he was because he
was he was hiding he wasn't
being a mexican his name was cheech
marin
yeah not much richard it was richard
barron yeah
we didn't we didn't know he was mexican
until we got to l.a
and we tried doing our canadian-born
jokes
in l.a yeah and one show just bombed
pretty bad and so we got to talk we
teach come on you're from here there
must be a character you can do
that people can understand tell me about
the low rider
and then we we crafted that that little
low rider
car bit and you're right and it started
as what about a five minute bit
yeah turned into a movie
yeah yeah that was well we both had the
same thought when we saw it we
met each other we looked at you like
what the [ __ ] are you
you're returning for what combination of
you know
have you guys actually been together
[ __ ]
since 69
69 69 60 [ __ ] nine yeah i played
every place you could play
68 69 dna me
that's our 47th you play san francisco
yeah the fillmore all those yeah time
goes by when you're stoned
yeah baby well actually it doesn't go by
time is invisible but what is time to a
pig
what is time to appear again
time is everything to everyone and
everything
yeah so talk to us a little bit about
the the cannabis business you know both
of you guys are
uh have you have your own companies oh
my my weed's way better than his
by far no we're we oh yeah we got uh
reggae reggae a reggae
do you know what a reggae is yes music
right
regulation a hey hey oh
really regulation
with my head don't you [ __ ] with me
man
hey we're raising money because we're
opening up
our pot shop in fact 420 we're going to
be
opening up our new sensory
dispensaries we're starting to change
some different sensories yeah
well we're going to be there as well
yeah hey man oh yeah
family affair yeah yeah and we're gonna
start opening them
uh as we raise money to open them so
stick them up
so we need people you know with money uh
like mike you know to really invest
heavily into our hearts yeah
there we go all right we're gonna grow
on this property you heard that
the lawyers dropped the
me contract brother yeah mike mike did
you know that
cheech is uh you start in your museums
uh sometime this year right for chicano
arts
yeah a year from now and it'll open a
year from now we're out in riverside
california
and i put together a big chica
collection of chicano art
for years and now how many we can see
that on the television
i'm sure we can send you images yeah
let's do that
yeah yeah yeah that's cool you've always
you've always had that love for uh
chicano culture because
me you know obviously growing up mexican
mike like he's
you know teaches he's a big deal in our
in our community you know
he's like yeah
yeah every committee but especially
friends worldwide
yeah you got a special place with you
joined hey brother let's smoke that's
the international uh
external line oh there it is wow you got
it way to go
it's a beautiful building it's a
mid-century building that
uh riverside uh riverside california was
the richest per capita
city in the united states in the 1880s
because of citrus
they grew valleys of oranges and lemons
and grapefruits and
and so they became very rich and so and
they commissioned all these historic
buildings
and this building that we're being given
to for the museum
is a classic mid-century building
what's that explosion right there yeah
explosion in the bayou
gas in the bayou it's this artist
margaret garcia
she's a og chicana painter
you know these guys have been working
for a long time you know
and developing this explanation of that
culture
and so it isn't a strict you know
a clinical or a technical
uh school it's it's it's an explanation
of a culture and the only way you can do
that
is you have to capture the sabor the
flavor of it
you know because it's told from a bunch
of different viewpoints whether it's
uh religious or personal
or uh
academic or historical then we put those
all together
who's that um diego sanchez is that his
name or
they have that girlfriend with the one
eyebrow oh frida kahlo
yeah but what's the guy named rivera the
eagle river yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
you're pretty good too though yeah those
guys are good
those are the guys of their days those
are mexicans chicago's are different
chicanos
are mexican-americans but but with a
defiant political attitude
now chicano was a derogatory term
from mexicans to other mexicans and the
concept being that the mexicans who were
living down the united states
were no longer mexicanos because they
left their country and they're living in
10 shacks a long time how can we fall
into that game that we no longer
allow ourselves to be the white people
did that too why why
why they did that they did it to each
other at that point
you're not you're not mexican anymore
you're something less yeah you're
smaller you're a chico you're a chicano
a little
satellite in mexico yeah exactly so
they took it as a badge of honor and uh
had this whole cultural explanation man
you know
yeah so that everybody should just you
know keep [ __ ] you sell
t-shirts that's the thing huh do you
have any t-shirts
i have oh shall we do chicano t-shirts
yes we do
okay this is chicano art is american art
you know really yeah yeah really yeah we
own this place at one time right
yeah yeah all i'm gonna say is i'm not
all this stuff we're in
el segundo like l.a
all the stuff right yeah el segundo
we're sitting right now this is the city
that we're in where does else
means the second the second the second
yeah like number first and then you got
number one
number two [ __ ] segundo
yeah because you're you're telling me
you're you're third generation right
mexican
generation yeah so he's been here mike
in this era since this was mexico like
his family
my my grandmother was born in tucson
uh when it was mexico
and then she woke up one day and it was
u.s
the next day you know so she didn't
cross the border to board across her
the world we live in
man it's really a pleasure to meet you
i'm i'm not kidding
i've seen you fight a lot of times man
well i've seen you on television
ferocious ferocious you hadn't attacked
it
thank you very much you couldn't be
stopped thank you thank you so much
i don't want to get in the ring with you
i don't want to get in the ring no more
either
no that's a charity yeah goofy
how was your relationship with gusta
motto very close
yeah bad huh very close i was very close
but i knew not to get too close
yeah that kind of yeah yeah yeah so
there's some
did gus get high
he drank but extreme disciplinary
yeah he'll go on fashion for 30 days
just for the hell of it you have to see
if he's strong
who was the doctor what's his name the
fight
freddie butcher afraid to protect armor
yeah i met him how was he in your corner
uh he was never in my corner but he was
really a good man and
by the time um i was fighting he was an
awesome commentator yeah yeah he was
good that's when i met him in in those
days man
it was a that was uh
i've been a boxing fan since i was born
i grew up in the shadow of olympic
auditorium really
yeah and i used to see um when i was a
young man
yeah yeah 12 30. i used to watch films
of um
what's the name of various bobby chacon
then i got old i watched bobby shakoma
he was a little boy when he started
fighting
so like in his like it's late 20s early
30s i started watching him he was just
watching salvador oh
[ __ ] oh danny little red lopez no
that's good super saiyan says oh they
don't know what we're talking about [ __ ]
you ever seen film films uh art aragon
fighting yes yes in the 50s
that was in the olympic auditorium and
everything that happened in l.a and
there's some
it's a korean church now you see it from
the freeway from the tenants are going
out east
and and everything was there boxing
wrestling
roller derby uh they filmed rocky there
the olympics were there
and it's the most historic building but
it's but i used to watch roller derby
there as a little kid because you could
get in free on tuesday though
it was women's night television yeah
it's been there forever huh
well your father boxed in the navy right
yeah he was boxing in a video
and we're just talking about how hard
that sport is the sport of boxing's so
that's a tough way to make it better
psychological sport more than anything
yes i would think
if more psychologically physical
yeah what do you think of the ufc you
i think that's beautiful yeah i like it
too i watch a lot of stuff
i like it i watch that more than
fighting yeah because this is what i
know
yeah i can look at a match and i'm not
sure this is going to be good enough i
can look at you saying no i'm going to
get entertained
that's uh i know it's just you're going
entertained you don't know those guys
if i don't know these guys i'm going to
ufc yeah
that's just the real deal yeah i watch
it a lot my wife
sits through it and she watches it too
she's rushing yeah my wife watches it as
well
dana and stuff and we like to see him
succeed so we just watch him she just
doesn't like watch politics
but she likes to do it
but she'll watch it during dinner huh
okay
where's where i i wanted to ask i wanted
to ask what are some of the
uh the best chi chi chong memories that
you guys uh
uh that you guys could share with us
who are some of the people you have met
man during the years
got everybody meeting any president we
used to play basketball in our
in tommy's driveway with bob dylan
really yeah he's a cool dude
yeah oh they had a guy had a shot he
beat his ass did his ass man
but uh but had a kiss shot and we used
to hang out because we all lived in
malibu out there at the end point doing
that
did you guys ever meet flint wilson and
all those guys out there
did you ever football son richard bryant
yeah
no risk of failure
used to live next door to me out there
too i knew sam
yeah he was he was crap the boo
looked down the boot for a long time uh
chichen chong right it's like you know
i think did you say buffa frog no boo
the the boo
malibu to the locals they call it the
boo
you ever heard of both for aloe veras
no the toad dmt
oh yeah the guard monocle
oh that's really interesting i don't
know them
guys oh that's the height it would last
for you
you guys look lighter there you go
yeah uh yeah no dmt guys i see huh
no dmt i uh uh
no i don't think so i checked out of
that scene at some point i respect that
yeah he was he just is that the guy just
i know that no
that's that's the max the emt is like um
oh
that natural yeah yeah that one monocle
we call it the guard monitor yeah you
got
code have you have you yeah have you
guys ever experienced
the the bull frog in that sense no
no i stay away from dangerous drugs like
that oh no not a drug of the medicine
what is that the bullfrog it's uh
toad right yeah it's the total it's a
frog that hibernates 11
11 months out of the year right mike or
10 months out of 10 months yeah 10
months out of the year
yes and they distract the dnt off and
then you can you can
puss in the licking the toes lick in the
toilet oh that we don't lick it
you just take the plus you put it in the
mirror at heart and you make it in the
fine
sand yeah and what's the effect what's
um let's see if you have the closest
experience to god that you
ever had in your life okay yeah so it's
it's uh it's a hallucination
yeah yeah where does it come from south
america no it's it's it's nice
it's uh it's northern mexico
and uh and and southern arizona
okay but they also have them in colorado
but this is one thing that mike has
experienced that has been
the 17th time really
does it is it the same experience every
time or different everything that's what
i'm
that's what that's what i'm baffled
about because how does it know to attack
that
part of your brain that won't repeat the
same thing
normally your mind made to repetition
represent that what drives us some crazy
repetition
but it doesn't at all it switches it
just blinds
it sucker punches the brain that's what
it does
boom you get something that you
anticipated from the last couple of
times it just doesn't work that way
it's not going to let you do what you
want to do
interesting what do you think you want
to do that you're not doing it
yeah yeah yeah you're not doing it yeah
i'm in control
it takes away everything you once your
ego is going you're going to be the
biggest [ __ ] in the world
and that's what we're made out of ego
yes without our ego we're in a lot of
trouble
don't believe that we're in the light of
happiness yeah
but it's not the enemy without it oh and
that's what the toad does it gives you
that happiness
and you say and it says dying is
beautiful if this is dying it's
beautiful
that's what the toad says so go lick a
toad
no no no you gotta smoke it no really
smoking i'll lick it till you smoke a
toad
if you lick a toe you gotta get
different it's not the same thing okay
i'm not gonna do that then
i know where you're going i've been
there
i've been there a couple of times yeah i
could dig it
that's why i asked you that you got kids
yeah i have kids
how many i have eight kids eight kids
yeah i've been busy
i have three kids that still live with
us he's a 10 year old
a 12 year old and an 18 year old
oh yeah nice do they live here
and with you here yeah one of them lived
in the 18 year old lived
in a house in vegas in vegas yeah yes
henderson huh
yes because he goes to school in usc but
he has to go to school on
on television i think yeah oh on june
zoom school yeah i'll zoom in but he
goes dancing he ain't the trojan
yeah i've been never been in his class
before my wife just goes to usa really
she's doing her doctorate in a piano
performance
yeah really yeah i grew up in the shadow
of usc my son is such an interesting guy
he goes to these places um he's a i'm
not i'm
i'ma say mercy he's a missionary
but he's a missionary and he goes to all
these places he goes places i wouldn't
think about going like haiti and all
these places
and he does his mission stuff no praise
god
jesus and all that whatever it is it's
good he's spreading love
that's just what he's about and you know
what he goes on he doesn't know
he he i gave him a nice
cadillac truck he traded in there for
and i thought i'd get you a new one
he said no that's okay he traded all
that stuff in one of those 150 rams
of course one of those hillbilly cars
but that's just who he is yes he's an
individual yeah he doesn't want no money
he doesn't want to take nothing from me
he wants to get everything on his own
and i'm saying fool i wish i had me
i was you and i would he was my father
okay that humbles me so much that for
him
he's good man but he never said the
disrespect he said no dad i'm okay he
won't take any money from me
nothing wow i'd have to discipline him
i'd have to make him take something yeah
man that's my ego though i want to be
able to do something from
the fact that i can't do anything for
him for him
it baffles me a little bit yeah it takes
away some part of my fatherhood
yeah at least i believe it does well you
know you could approve of his life
of his choices you know that that
strengthens his faith in all the right
choices
this is good approve of them he's a good
he's a he's a good kid
i don't i don't know mike but i can tell
he's a good kid yes straight kid
never cheated on his girlfriend he's
just not that guy
yeah leaving god all he said yeah this
is good for him he's a young preacher
doing good spreading spreading help out
there that's good man yeah i'd be proud
of him good for me really
yeah i really
yeah let them know that this is good man
i'm glad you're happy in life now i'm
glad you're happy in life now
happiness is the moment yes it is
what possessed you to get that tattoo on
your face i thought it was beautiful
but what what was the impulse to do that
i don't know i just wanted that there
you go
that's a commitment huh nah it's not a
commitment because you have to look at
um
our life and our body we belong to the
world we are we are
um yeah a map and the world's rightness
is hard on us what do you think started
this whole tattoo craze
i mean there's everybody's got tattoos
all over everywhere and
everywhere you go no it's around the
world time goes on and generations go
and
people evolve and become more conscious
and trying to find out who they are
where they came from
uh-huh you think that's what's going on
right now
absolutely okay do you want a tattoo no
but it's not but it's not the con
but it's not you don't have to do that
consciousness looks like it hurts
yeah yeah i understand what you mean and
and and
and it's advertising because it's so
visible you know because
from the time you got this tattoo to now
tattoos face tattoos are very common but
it wasn't then
not when you did it no it wasn't like
it's like you know the commitment
at that time at that level i was in that
i was in a really ferocious state of
mind
but now it doesn't it's it's evolved and
and doesn't indicate that anymore but
it's
it's prevalent everywhere you know we we
live and god creates
yeah yeah we don't know what's going on
we don't even understand who we
listen we may i may think i'm 55 but
i don't know who i am i don't know how
[ __ ] old i am
before before jesus julius caesar were
born
how did they tell how old they were like
how did alexander the great and those
guys
tell their age my moons yeah
how do we know how old we are it's
it's arbitrary we agreed to it yeah
agreed
yeah exactly man what do you say
uh that this world was created for
somebody getting high
that's not what i heard yeah so i got
high say hey we're gonna make this look
like this
we'll put the clouds here with the water
here
that's what i heard before i steal it oh
no please it'll be a pleasure to
give you this souvenir just let me use
it
i don't know about you guys but i am
really [ __ ] up
really i am so high to the highest of
activities
who am i smoking the reds baby
what is this oh this is that's the rash
this is the red roses
look at the back that's just good yeah
yeah that's right you should be a
rancher
and they have a love baby and they'll
help ourselves after it's good
i don't want this to ever end right now
just stay here for two days bring out
bring out the mushrooms mike
oh no no
i haven't done the mushroom for a while
somebody gonna hit me so hard
oh no not to shrew me dave god
man those i think i could do it right
now man no
yeah oh you knew who i met i was just in
this movie
and lenny kravitz was in it all right
and he and he talked really good about
you man that's my buddy
yeah lenny my buddy
that was interesting
and look how good he looks god damn
that's his job i mean it really is yeah
brother yeah he's a good kid
a kid kid
what's going on but he grew up on cheech
and chong too yeah yeah because he grew
up in l.a
him and sloths
guns and roses yeah they went to beverly
high they were the
two black kids in beverly hills like
jewish
kids yeah exactly they had to stick
together baby
yeah describe you how was your career
how would you describe you guys career
like in a nutshell
are you guys too high to you guys to
hide
in a nutshell we prospered best when we
were
you can in the moment pecan pecan nuts
and i'll say duration probably walnut
it's being in the moment and we've been
in the moment
for a long stretch in different periods
and that's why we're
here you know between those the record
years and the stage years and then
and then the movies and then after the
movie years and then the separate years
and then the comeback years and you know
we've endured through all those years
and i guess it's
our natural calling imagine living high
every day of your life
i'm like that level don't munch and i
know it's just an incredible feeling
being high
and have that and i thought i meant like
hey we're [ __ ] up i hide
it the highest form of thinking not this
side
my height is the highest form of
thinking right now
i don't want your guys believe we should
put these guys and straight jackets and
just keep them here huh
uh she said
you got what you guys gonna do after
this something
okay we're gonna separate once you're
leaving reggae we live in the we live in
the same neighborhood yeah we always
kind of
eventually move next to each other for
some reason
over the years i move and he follows i
follow him i see that i see that
that's okay yeah since nineteen so
nice it was uh
it was vancouver was like the san
francisco of of canada
during the hippie period it was like
like san francisco so that's vancouver's
so [ __ ] clean though right
very clean man i wonder what the [ __ ] am
i doing here man it's a beautiful place
off the floor it's hung cooper now
vancouver
vancouver it's 70 70 chinese now really
yeah more like
80. is it eight that's beautiful baby
yeah everybody lives
we're taking over it always had a big
chinese
it was half second biggest china they
love each other
yeah they were good and they all love
each other like
it hung could ruin
this [ __ ] oh man this is so
um okay usually
that's some good weed
i'm curious you're with you're celibates
with uh
with the with the wolf of wall street
jordan belford jordan bill for check
this durian really
do you know this mike we never had sex
i'm sorry i said we never had sex what
about jordan
but we were selling you know him
jordan's a cool guy
he was tommy's cellmate yeah i thought
joe was the cool guy that
i thought talked to him once on i think
zoom but i think he was that guy
everybody's not with the presidio i know
that next time you see jordan
ask him about uh uh the stallone style
stone
very interesting story what do you guys
think about the set man
i like it it's relaxing it'd make a nice
warehouse
that's what it is
well guys you guys thank you guys man
this is this has been awesome man you
guys are
honored you guys are iconic man iconic
is that true i live in a
any last words here mike man i
i'm stuck for words when this isn't the
real um keep on going
yeah keep on doing what you're doing
your honor really thank you really
yeah she can [ __ ] it try to be a little
more mike tyson
you have to be humble to this brother
all right that's it guys
nice mistake it's mike tyson that's this
is the one this is my best all-time
great
right there podcast ever thank you guys
thank you
you